place au match des idées confrontation
de points de vue ce soir entre béatrice
giblin et nicolas tenzer match
international qu'on va ouvrir par les
tensions au proche orient depuis hier
plusieurs centaines de roquettes ont été
tirés de gaza vers israël l'armée
israélienne a riposté en visant près de
150 cibles militaires palestiniennes des
membres du rpt hamas et du jihad
islamique ont été tués mais aussi des
civils
pourquoi cette soudaine et très violente
flambée de violence l'analyse de nos
invités juste après les faits avec
fabien eckert depuis la bande de gaza ce
matin des salves de roquettes tirées
vers israël
intercepté par le bouclier antimissile
de l'état hébreu ces tirs ont pourtant
causé la mort de deux femmes
israéliennes dans le sud du pays une
riposte aux frappes israéliennes sur
gaza qui aurait fait la veille 26 morts
dont neuf enfants et 125 blessés selon
les autorités palestiniennes des frappes
justifié par benyamin nétanyahou
les organisations terroristes à gaza ont
franchi une ligne rouge en tirant des
roquettes
jusque dans la région de jérusalem au
total des tirs de roquettes palestiniens
déclenchés après plusieurs jours de
violence à jérusalem est
depuis vendredi les affrontements entre
manifestants palestiniens et policiers
israéliens ont fait rage sur l'esplanade
des mosquées
l'onu s'est dit aujourd'hui très
inquiète de cette escalade de la
violence
par la voix de jean baptiste lemoyne la
france appelle au calme
oui nous condamnons fermement les tirs
de roquettes depuis la bande de gaza
nous appelons aussi des autorités
israéliennes à un usage proportionné de
la force très clairement ces tensions
oui elles font craindre une escalade de
grande ampleur car en l'absence de toute
perspective de reprise d'un processus de
paix le conflit pourrait s'installer
dans la durée en israël et chez elle
signe un on est soit trop divisés soit
en pleine crise
politico-institutionnelle conséquent
encore une fois il ya pour l'instant en
tout cas de perspectives l'armée
israélienne a affirmé mardi avoir tué 15
membres du hamas et du jihad islamique à
gaza
les tensions à jérusalem et en
cisjordanie aurait quant à elle déjà
causé plus de 900 blessés palestiniens
selon le croissant rouge avec nous pour
ce match des idées international
béatrice giblin bienvenue géopolitologue
géographe directrice de la revue
hérodote nicolas tenzer bienvenue à vous
également spécialiste des questions
stratégiques et internationales
président fondateur du centre d'étude et
de réflexion pour l'action politique et
directeur de la revue le banquet j'ai
tout dis bienvenue à tous les deux en
deux ou trois jours mais est rigide
blain la situation a complètement
explosé complètement dégénérée c'est
vrai que vu de france on peut se
demander pourquoi ça a explosé si
violemment d'un coup que s'est il passé
pas parce que la situation est d'une
tension extrême mais j'ai envie d'y
aller puis des décès de louis mais on
est à la fin du ramadan pour coter pas
des signes assez le dernier vendredi
était vendredi dernier puisque ça se
terminera demain je crois le ramadan
dans une situation qui est extrêmement
difficile et bien évidemment une
division des palestiniens qui est très
très forte entre le hamas ans le 16
autorité palestinienne
par ailleurs il devait y avoir des
élections y en a pas eu depuis 15 ans et
elles sont de nouveau repoussé avec
quand même un leader qui est âgée
qui a 85 ans très corrompu donc vraiment
une situation c'est de désespoir si vous
voulez passer de population est là avec
une spécialisation importante puisqu'il
s'agit en fait au bénéfice de colons
juifs d'expulser des familles
palestiniennes de jérusalem-est qui est
un territoire occupé et sur le droit
international
on n'a pas le droit d'expulser des
civils sur un territoire occupé au nom
d'un droit de propriété qu'auraient ces
familles juives d'avant 1948
or vous savez comme moi qu israël ait
créé en 1940 mais des ions été suspendus
ou pas c'est ce qu'on a cru comprendre
ces derniers jours et à l'expulsion des
familles elle a été suspendue
elle a pas été vraiment sur le tribunal
n'a pas rendu ses il le devait donner un
avis lundi
d'accord lui ne l'a pas donnée lundi
alors quand c'est un geste d'apaisement
ça ou pas du tout je suis pas sûr que ce
soit un geste d'apaisement j'en suis pas
certaine de toute façon la spirale de la
violence est quand même sorti très
fortement avec l'axé justement sur
l'esplanade des mosquées qui est très
important c'est jérusalem seamless et
trois monothéismes sur un tout il faut
toujours avoir dans la tête comme ordre
de grandeur que la vis à vis de
jérusalem tient sur la place de la
concorde
c'est à dire qu'il faut pas imaginer
qu'on a de la place et les compagnies
air minus est minuscule et c'est très
important de le savoir
alors cette chaleur ce droit foncier
antérieur à 1948 et bien évidemment n'a
aucune réciprocité du côté palestinien
et comme je me disais frédéric encel on
est dans une situation politique du côté
israélien qui est absolument très plus
que préoccupante on vient de refaire
encore des élections on arrive toujours
pas avoir de gouvernement et on a des
des juifs orthodoxes d'extrême droite
qui pousse qui poussent sans arrêt et
aux fonds qui met peu d'huile sur le feu
vous savez c'est une très vieille
histoire ce rachat des maisons dans la
devant chez russe à l'aise ça ça dure
déjà depuis des années et des adouls la
question qui revient toujours pourquoi
ça explose maintenant est ce que c'est
une situation qui est naturel yalala qui
vise aussi à ça j'essaie conjoncturelles
nicolas tenzer quelle est votre analyse
t elle je pense que ça explose
maintenant en raison d'un élément
déclencheur qui effectivement sont ces
expulsions de sheikh jarrah ça c'est
tout à fait évident et ça couvait ça
couvait de ce2 fuit depuis depuis
longtemps et après il ya la circonstance
qui fait que toutes les choses
s'enchaînent et puis il ya le contexte
qui a été très bien décrit je suis
entièrement d'accord avec ce qui vient
d'être dit qu' effectivement un contexte
où on a deux parties qui ne cherche
absolument pas à trouver une solution
une radicalisation évidemment du côté
israélien avec un gouvernement de droite
sinon même d'extrême droite en tout cas
très fortement poussé par cette extrême
droite pour faire absolument non
concession aucune concession qui
considère que finalement la seule
solution c'est le rapport de force
et puis d'un autre côté effectivement
aussi un mouvement terroriste le hamas
qui essayent là aussi une chercheuse de
frappe avec cette pluie de roquettes
s'est renforcée romain le ramasser
renforcés bien sûr il reçoit et des
livraisons d'armes
on le sait effectivement d'un certain
nombre de dettes apparaît que ce soit
l'iran ou d'autres ça c'est tout à fait
évident on a avec un gouvernement
totalement dysfonctionnelle de
l'autorité palestinienne et cela n'aide
pas la situation en israël n'aide pas
non plus à stabiliser la situation avec
la présidence trump on a eu
effectivement une sorte de lâchage de
brie où on voyait finalement que les
seuls qui peuvent garantir et essayer de
remettre tout le monde autour d'une
table de négociations si difficile que
cela soit ce sont quand même les états
unis et avec 36 à changer quelque chose
maiden pas alors valdaine pourrait
changer je pense que c'est là où on a
une possibilité je suis pas du tout
certain que cela sa façon une
possibilité que joe biden et son équipe
s'investissent beaucoup plus sur la
question ya pas de position unilatérale
de l'administration by donne bien sûr
l'administration by dane est très
prudente en raison de l'électorat juif
américain
mais considère depuis toujours qu'il
faut trouver une solution et la seule
solution tout le monde le sait c'est la
solution à deux états il n'y a pas
d'autre solution que celle là mais qui
bute qui a toujours goûter même sur
toutes les négociations qui semblaient
aboutir même les accords de camp david
sur précisément le statut de jérusalem
et c'est le statut de jérusalem qui est
le point essentiel de blocage même du
côté de ce qu'on pourrait appeler les
modérés et on voit une diplomatie
internationale complètement impuissant
et ce n'est pas un conseil de sécurité
avait nui hier ils débouchent sur rien
et c'est absolument pas possible parce
que comme vous venez de le rappeler vous
avez un lobby pro israélien qui pèse
très fortement aux états unis et les
états unis ne lâcheront pas jamais et
israël donc de toute façon quelle quelle
position prendre véritablement tout le
monde dit qu'il faut 2 et à cesser dit
depuis des décennies et des décennies si
vous voulez mais là où c'est quand même
la situation à mon avis est plus grave
parce qu'il n'ya pas que jérusalem
on a quand même toute une stratégie
d'implantation de colonies sur des
territoires qui sont des territoires
palestiniens et de et quand même avec
une une chaise dire ça fait maintenant
de là aussi des décennies c'est bien que
ces sont des centaines de milliers de
colons juifs qui sont installés et alors
il ya évidemment les avant-postes sur
des colons les plus radicaux qui sont
effectivement j'allais dire au coeur
même de ce qui est la sienne devant dany
detec a pas des signes assez vrai et le
rapport de force pour les israéliens
c'est qu'une affaire de temps et in fine
est ils sont absolument convaincus
qu'ils finiront par l'emporter et la
stratégie du pacte d'abraham où on à
israël qui commencent à placer ses pions
avec bahreïn et les émirats arabes unis
en attendant peut-être que ces pièces
venir de l'arabie saoudite leur donne
effectivement là la conviction qu'ils
vont et y arriver que tout le monde au
fonds à lâcher les palestiniens et
parfois on en arrive à se dire mais il
faudrait vraiment qu'ils aient de
tragédie sanglante abominable pour que
devant tant d'horreurs tout d'un coup
les choses arrivent c'est bloqué bien
évidemment c'est parce qu'il faut
souhaiter bien sûr avec le corps une
fois je pense qu'il ya deux parties
pardon excusez moi tu n'as il ya 2 il ya
deux parties effectivement qui encore
une fois se radicalise à dire que la
société israélienne en 30 ans a
également considérablement changé et
aujourd'hui on a quand même beaucoup
moins de modérer tout ce qui faisait l
israël d'autrefois qui était astreinte
de personnages éclairé qui cherchait la
paix qui étaient convaincus par un
certain nombre de valeurs de droit et de
la loi sur l'impulsion de netanyahu
netanyahu c'est à dire qu'il ya un
phénomène démographique il ya eu des
vagues avec des bâtiments des vagues
d'immigration de gens qui étaient tout à
fait différente et relisent d'esprit
excellent qui ne connaissait plus en
gros cet esprit des pionniers des
kibboutzim que l'on avait effectivement
au début et du côté palestinien en
raison aussi de l'oppression très
profonde qu'exerce le hamas et
l'autorité palestinienne nous avons
aussi des intellectuels palestiniens
modérés prêt à tendre la main qui sont
également partis il ya beaucoup de
palestiniens qui m'ont dit mais de toute
manière
indépendamment d'israël nous ne
pourrions pas vivre non plus dans les
territoires tels qu'ils sont aujourd'hui
c'est invivable ya tellement de pression
human watch ocz a dénoncé les violations
constantes des droits fondamentaux des
palestiniens qui vit dans c'était donc
on a encore une fois une radicalisation
des deux côtés et c'est ça qui j'avais
une très très forte émigration
palestinienne c'est à dire que tous ceux
qui veulent avoir un peu un projet de
vie pour leurs familles leurs afin de
l'enfant s'ils peuvent partir il y pas
arrive au pas ils vont royaume uni vont
aux états unis d'ailleurs pour un grand
nom en suède
et voilà ils s'en vont parce que c'est
ils peuvent plus aller autant dans les
pays du golfe qu'ils y sont elles est
une période
enfin bon il est pas loin de bosses
estimé aussi trahi d'ailleurs partie
cela creuse autorités paix la guerre
très longtemps et la glace par an mais
de là à ce moment j'allais dire laisse
un peu tomber donc il reste vraiment
dans une situation de grande pauvreté de
grande tension avec un écoeurement
demain de l'encadrement politique qu'ils
ont vraiment qui est franchement
désespérant une impasse sur laquelle on
reviendra mais on va passer au deuxième
thème si vous le voulez bien deuxième
sujet international
analyse et non annulée avec vous ce soir
c'est la victoire des indépendantistes
en écosse nouvelle épine dans le pied de
boris johnson après celle de
l'interminable le bric site c'est un
sujet que vous avez peut-être peu suivi
ces derniers jours pourtant ce qui s'est
passé samedi en écosse et historique
à en croire la première ministre écoute
et les résultats de cette élection sont
extraordinaires et historique avec cette
élection les écossais doivent avoir le
droit de décider de leur futur quand la
crise sanitaire sera derrière nous
le référendum est fondamentalement une
question de principe démocratique
boris johnson n'a aucun argument pour
bloquer la volonté des écossais alors
avant d'en parler avec vous sur ce
plateau voyons ce qu'on pense à ça ça
m'a keroman bienvenus vous êtes
correspondante de rfi en écosse auteurs
de ce livre écosse adrien et la licorne
merci d'être avec nous ce soir on va
vers un référendum sur l'indépendance de
l'écossé où c'est plus compliqué qu'il
n'y paraît alors c'est un peu plus
compliqué qu'il n'y paraît donc les
écossais se sont prononcés jeudi dernier
dans les urnes pour élire leurs députés
au parlement écossais qui un parlement
qui a été créée en 99 un parlement
décentralisée qui a beaucoup de pouvoir
beaucoup d'autonomie et près de la
moitié d'entre eux ont porté leurs voix
sur le fn qui est donc le parti des
connaisseurs de jeunes et aussi les
verts qui sont prend indépendance et la
moitié d'entre eux se sont portés sur
les autres partis qui se prononce contre
l'indépendance et en fait même contre un
référendum
donc il ya une grande majorité au
parlement écossais indépendantiste avec
72 députés contre conques les scènes qui
plus sévère qu'ils veulent avoir un
nouveau référendum d'indépendance dans
les prochaines années
une minorité de députés prg au royaume
uni mais dans l'opinion publique
écossaise s'est un peu 55 ans donc il y
en a il ya la moitié des gens qui est
plutôt ouverte à l'idée d'avoir un
référendum si ce n'est d'avoir
l'indépendance et l'autre moitié qui se
dit que c'est pas le moment ou pas du
tout même une bonne idée
de parler de l'indépendance maintenant
et quelles peuvent être les éléments de
langage d'un boris johnson qui a voulu
être lui même indépendant de l'union
européenne comment va-t-il pouvoir dire
aux écossais pour vous il y aura pas de
référendum sur l'indépendance comment
peut-il tenir cette ligne
et bien justement lui ce qu'il dit c'est
que ce n'est absolument pas le moment on
est encore dans la crise sanitaire on a
probablement beaucoup d'efforts à faire
pour un rebond économique dans les
prochains mois et les prochaines années
et pour lui ce n'est absolument pas la
question ans est l'indépendance il pense
que l'ecosse a beaucoup plu avantage à
rester dans le royaume uni car en sortir
notamment il parle du programme vaccinal
il dit que si ce n'était pas pour les
actions du royaume uni l'ecosse
aujourd'hui ne serait probablement pas
en situation de pouvoir d confiné aussi
vite et aussi loin qu elle le fait
maintenant
et en plus de ça ce que disent
maintenant les unionistes en particulier
le gouvernement conservateur c'est qu'il
ya légèrement plus de personnes qui ont
voté pour des partis sionistes que pour
des partis indépendantistes
après bien sûr le problème c'est on est
dans une démocratie parlementaire et
c'est compliqué de dire que le parlement
britannique en 2019 avait un mandat pour
effectuer le brésil avec à peu près 40
3% des votes exprimés à l'échelle du
royaume uni mais que de l'autre côté les
écossais qui élisent ce gouvernement
indépendantiste
avec 48% des voix à eux n'ont pas de
mandat et non pas de droit en fait
d'exiger un nouveau référendum
d'indépendance
donc on a on a un peu de magie mesure de
ce côté là c'est une ligne qui est un
peu compliqué à tenir du côté des
conservateurs mes partenaires ne nous
dit que dans les prochains mois même si
ces prochaines semaines leur position ne
va pas légèrement et aujourd'hui vous
avez parlé du bric site est ce qu'on
n'est pas en effet effectivement dans
des effets un peu à retardement d'un
bric site que les écossais ne voulais
pas tout à fait là clairement c'est ce
qui a beaucoup changé les choses en
écosse depuis 2016 dont 2016 c'était
l'année des dernières élections elles
ont eu lieu en mai 2016 c'était un mois
avant
faire un dogme sur l'appartenance du
royaume-uni à l'union européenne mais
c'est passé ce vrai exit les écossais
ont massivement voté contre la sortie de
l'union européenne et en plus de ça il
ya eu la pandémie et la gestion de
coronavirus qui a été perçu comme plus
prudente meilleur plus humaine du côté
de l'ecosse ont comparé à la gestion des
conservateurs a longtemps fait la santé
c'est un domaine décentralisée donc en
fait les quatre nations constitutives du
royaume uni ont chacune une politique de
santé et tout le monde n'a pas été au
même rythme et tout le monde n'a pas
pris les mêmes mesures donc en voyant en
fait des décisions de j ou de mort qui
ont été prises au niveau écossais et des
effets que ça a pu donner
il y en a beaucoup qui se sont dit
qu'ils avaient quand même pas mal de
mérite à l'autodétermination et à
l'autonomie est peut-être qu'il fallait
continuer le chemin et aller carrément
vers l'indépendance
restez avec nous à samaké roman on va
continuer d'en discuter en plateau et
vous manifestez évidemment si vous
souhaitez répondre nicolas tenzer c'est
pas un petit sujet j'imagine pour boris
johnson est ce que finalement ce bric si
tu ne vas pas avoir des conséquences
comme ça un peu
plusieurs conséquences par ailleurs il
ya plusieurs conséquences il ya eu
d'abord les conséquences sur l'irlande
et l'irlande du nord et en particulier
on y pense tout de suite on à l'école
sont n'a potentiellement le pays de
galles où on a vu avec les dernières
élections
une majorité travailliste de l'emporter
alors on n'est pas encore sûr une
volonté d'indépendance du pays de galles
mais enfin quand même on a des tendances
quand même sécessionnistes dit une
d'absence de satisfaction globale
vis-à-vis de ce gouvernement du côté de
ces régions là c'est tout à fait évident
et maintenant il ya quand même une
volonté de la barre de boris johnson et
je pense qu'un gouvernement travaille ce
serait quand même dans la même position
même s'il n'aurait pas eu les mêmes un
précédent de dire mais on ne peut pas
largué une partie une partie du
territoire d'abord parce que comme le
savoir on a aussi une base de quand même
2 e nucléraire je dirais en écosse ce
qui n'est pas tout à fait un petit sujet
sur les questions de sécurité et de
défense
et puis je pense que boris johnson se
dit bon sur le plan du droit on sait que
le droit britannique est
particulièrement flexible donc aussi la
haute cour était saisie on ne sait pas
exactement ce qu'elle pourrait
finalement dire parce que on sait que
nicolas star john la première ministre
écossaise entend appeler évidemment
audrey que la cour se prononce sur le
sujet mais c'est pas du tout sûr que la
cour donne satisfaction à l'ecosse et
incertitudes et puis du côté européen
alors l'europe est très silencieuse mais
il faut quand même le mentionner
l'europe n'a pas nécessairement envie
non pas d'accueillir les écossais qui
sont des amis des gens charmants etc
mais tout simplement parce que vis-à-vis
d'un certain nombre d'autres pays on
pense évidemment à l'espagne avec le
problème de la catalogne aussi sa
terreur ou la belgique bien sûr aussi ne
voudrais pas non plus imaginer qu'il ya
une sorte de loup de la bergerie qui
pourrait permettre de donner une
légitimité à toutes les autres
tentatives de sécession entre guillemets
et je pense que ça aussi chacun le sait
je vous donne la parole dans un instant
béatrice giblin mais je crois qu'à
samaké roman veut réagir
8h et sur la question de l'eau
ça c'est quelque chose qui intéresse
énormément il en est pendante east eux
de leur côté ils veulent un référendum
qu'ils soient légales le plus carré
possible justement parce qu'ils leur
rêve d'indépendance et l'indépendance
dans l'union européenne dont qui veulent
quelque chose qui soit reconnue par
toute la communauté internationale qui
sont absolument indiscutable pour pas se
retrouver dans un cas qui soit similaire
à celui de la catalogne et de l'espagne
mais il ya eu un gros travail qui a été
fait ces dernières années pour si ce
n'est pas pour parler directement de
l'indépendance que ça serait assez
étonnant qu une des capitales
européennes se prononce pour ou contre
l'autodétermination écosse en tout cas
pour dire que les causes étaient
toujours là les corses avaient envie de
discuter avec les partenaires européens
et que voilà joue ça viendrait les
causes seraient un partenaire de
l'europe
donc il ya vraiment eu un très très gros
travail qui a été fait ces dernières
années notamment en ouvrant des hubs du
gouvernement écossais dans plusieurs
capitales européennes notamment à paris
il semble que c'est en 2018 est vraiment
pour avoir un dialogue avec la france
l'allemagne l'espagne et aussi des pays
nordiques
d'après gilbert oui je pense que il ya
un certain romantisme allait pas à
l'indépendance en pensant que voilà on
sera merveilleux puisque on sera
indépendant je pense que comme ça a été
très justement rappelé il ya la moitié
des électeurs qui n'ont pas voté pour le
parti indépendantiste donc il ya déjà eu
un référendum il y avait eu une majorité
pour dire qu'il voulait rester dans le
cadre du royaume uni ça me fait penser
un peu au québec si vous voulez vous
souvenez vous il ya eu quand même que jr
référendum
et puis c'est référendum ont toujours
été favorables pour rester quand même
dans
l'état à deux nations cake et le canada
et je pense que même si on fait du
lobbying négocier sans très gentil et
très sympathique on fera tout bien comme
il faut faire n'est pas comme les
catalans et encore moins comme les
basques je pense que pour l'europe c'est
la commission européenne mais les états
européens le conseil européen ce serait
un risque énorme
parce que si on l'europe
l'ecosse obtient son indépendance parce
que ça d'une intervention bruxelles a
rien à dire l'europe n'a rien à dire ça
il le fera dans le cadre évidemment du
royaume uni mais quand les causes
viendra à venir
toc toc toc maintenant on rentre dans
l'europe à nous on est bien d'accord il
n'est pas sûr du tout que l'ensemble des
autres partenaires à la campa ce que les
flamands n'attendent qu'une chose hein
c'est c'est eux qui ont accueilli fiq
damon les catalans chez eux en flandre
et eux poussent à cela je suis pas du
tout certaine qui est un nom tout zias
mme comme ça pour accueillir les gentils
écossais avec les risques que ça
pourrait avoir de ses parts à 6 ou de
sécession disent qu'ils seraient
possibles font de voiliers à la boîte de
franchement vous croyez vraiment que les
espagnols avec le gouvernement espagnol
est que la majorité des espagnols
verrait santa bonnal
or l'espagne ça compte dans
dans l'union le risque politique mais il
y aussi le risque économique parce que
pour l'instant le reste du royaume uni
et subventionne de fait les cos et s'il
n'y avait plus le royaume uni d'abord ça
poserait un gros problème quand même
pour les causes et donc pour les
écossais en termes d'emploi de niveau de
vie et cetera mais onze idiot mais ce
que le rpt va remplacer je pense dans le
contexte aujourd'hui on peut quand même
douté que l'europe soit prête à donner
des fonds de cohésion supplémentaires ou
spéciaux à l'ecosse c'est un peu fini
aussi et on va passer à l'autre
actualité internationale je vous
remercie infiniment à samaké roman
d'avoir été avec nous ce soir d'être
intervenu ponctuellement dans ce match
et peut-être que vous reviendrez pour
reparler de l'ecosse dans ce dans cette
émission autre actualité internationale
ce sujet brûlant qui revient dans le
débat public en italie cette fois et qui
devient donc là aussi un sujet pour
l'europe 2128 personnes ont débarqué ces
derniers jours sur lampedusa qui ne peut
accueillir en principe que 250 migrants
et viennent pour la plupart des côtes
libyennes
tout occupé à la gestion du coc vie de
mario draghi voir ressurgir la question
migratoire phénomène qu'il prend très au
sérieux puisque c'est ce phénomène qui a
favorisé la montée du populisme ces
dernières années d'ailleurs la droite
nationaliste n'a pas tardé à interpeller
président du conseil est coté encore une
fois l'europe manquent à l'appel cette
histoire ne l'intéressent pas il faut
donc que nous fassions les choses par
nous mêmes comme je lé fais quand nous
étions au gouvernement nous avions
réduit le nombre d'embarcations de 90 %
et le nombre de morts il faut donc
travailler avec la libye la tunisie et
les pays de départ afin d'éviter de
nouveaux morts les italiens n'ont pas
besoin de nouveaux problèmes
ils doivent déjà affronter le co vide et
le chômage b est risible est-ce que cet
afflux soudain de migrants pourraient
déstabiliser la majorité de mario draghi
voire plus je suis pas sûr que ça
veulent la déstabiliser mais que ça
oppose de nouveau un très très gros
problèmes à l'italie
mais comme vous l'avez dit mais ça pose
aussi un problème à l'europe penny faut
regarder les choses en face
ces arrivées massives ça vient des côtes
libyennes et ça vient aussi beaucoup de
tunisie c'est à dire que la situation en
chine en tunisie aujourd'hui sur le plan
économique est extrêmement
difficile sur le plan politique c'est
vraiment plus que fragile et donc il ya
beaucoup de jeunes tunisiens qui part
j'allais dire désespoir ou au contraire
espoir d'une vie médias vont partir on
ne connaît pas les nationalités des
différents migrants qui sont arrivés
mais c'est évident si vous voulez que et
la situation en libye
même s'il ya maintenant un gouvernement
d'union mais qui vient seulement d'être
installé sur une situation qui reste
extrêmement chaotique est extrêmement
fragile avec tout ce que ça veut dire de
corruption possible avec des passeurs
avec y compris de ceux à qui on confie
qu'il ne contrôle plus les bateaux il
nous convie au contrôle du lab alors là
lors qu'ils sont censés le faire alors
oui bien sûr mais bon on achète on paye
encore on et puis on est tous arrivés
les migrants c'est un business
absolument colossal c'est beaucoup
d'argent qui circule avec les migrants
qui on le revoit toujours l'idée de la
pauvreté mais il ya énormément d'argent
un pont pour les passages les passages
pour aller en angleterre de calais ses
3000 euros 1 donc c'est mais il faut
avoir conscience
alors quand il ya beaucoup d'argent à
faire vous aurez toujours des gens pour
laisser passer et s'est passé est donné
à penser que la chance est là et que ce
sera possible
et c'est une vraie question pour pour
l'europe alors on avait trouvé une
solution parce que c'est normalement au
débarque dans le pays le plus proche où
on est bon on avait trouvé l'idée que ça
pourrait peut-être se répartir un peu le
plus équitablement sur les pays autour
de la méditerranée
mais si vous voulez tout va s'arrêter à
cause du coup vite ça voilà et tout le
monde est tellement sûr j'allais dire
plus que prudent avec une extrême droite
embusqués voire même une bonne droite un
peu radicale quand elle n'est pas au
pouvoir et qui en profite
que personne n'ose véritablement prendre
le sujet le sujet regardez quand angela
merkel a
vers est a dit bon ben on se mit on l'a
on le prend et puis on va y arriver
vous avez une extrême droite en
allemagne qui a flambé aussitôt le
contexte en france est pas meilleur sur
merkel c'est vrai mais en même temps son
wirtschaft und das nous allons nous
allons y arriver en fête a été un succès
mais parce qu'il s'était aussi des
d'ailleurs à claudie d'ailleurs par le
patronat allemand qui a trouvé avec les
syriens en particulier une main d'oeuvre
d'une qualité absolument exceptionnel et
c'est ce qui n'est pas toujours le cas
et l'extrême droite allemande a
effectivement monté vous l'avez rappelé
et après elle a quand même un tout petit
peu diminué heureusement d'ailleurs
au cours des dernières années mais cela
on est dans une autre catégorie on est
sur autre chose on est d'abord sur une
absence totale effectivement de
solidarité européenne je pense qu
indépendamment de lakovic 19
je pense qu il n'y avait pas d'accord
notamment d'un certain nombre de pays
d'europe de l'est pas plus tellement de
la france les accords de malte c'est
sardon ce sont les accords demain voilà
exactement ce qu'avait pris à partie
selon ding mais lord en même temps ça
n'a jamais fonctionné il ya toujours eu
trop d des états qui ont dit de deux
manières il n'est pas question chez nous
ça va déstabiliser notre société et
c'est pour des raisons qui ont été
invités on voit aujourd'hui indiqué on
voit aujourd'hui la france d'ailleurs un
certain nombre de personnes y compris
pas seulement de la droite extrême voilà
qui aujourd'hui réchigne beaucoup même
les déclarations de monsieur barnier
ouais j'ai seulement il ya quand même
cette réalité je dirai rien qui est qu
on ne va pas arrêter les migrations à la
fois pour les raisons que vous avez
indiquée mais aussi parce qu'il ya une
pression politique une pression
économique une pression sociale où les
gens préfèrent risquer le pire le pire
arrive 1 3 159 morts depuis le début de
l'année en méditerranée plus d'un
millier l'année dernière c'est comme une
catastrophe absolument terrible mais les
gens ils sont prêts à tout risquer pour
partir et ce n'est pas un mur ce ne sont
pas en refoulant des gens à belgrade
ailleurs que monsieur salvini que vous
avez montré tout à l'heure à le
représentant de la lega l'extrême droite
italienne ancien vice président du
conseil est d'ailleurs poursuivi devant
les tribunaux italiens pour avoir fait
refluer
un bateau de migrants faut pas l'oublier
non plus et donc aujourd'hui il n'y a
rien à attendre de leur atteint voilà on
est on est les actions lancées mais
effectivement là dessus il ya un vrai
point c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui on est
dans un égoïsme national et c'est vrai
que cet égoïsme avec la crise économique
même avant le coc vide encore plus avec
effectivement absolument va renforcer
effectivement cette absence totale elle
solidarité on ne traite pas le sujet on
ne traite pas le sujet c'est très sexy
difficile à traiter le sujet fait chacun
est extrêmement prudent il faudrait le
traité bon il est tout le monde est
important mais je pense que draghi elle
est différent si vous voulez de la
période où c'était mouvement 5 étoiles
et la ligue
draghi à une autorité en europe il a un
poids en europe c'est à dire que il sera
capable de se faire entendre c'est là où
on n'est pas de rendement produit
c'est là où on n'est pas un peu d'espoir
ça fait du bien sûr dans la même
configuration que ce qu'on était à
l'époque de salvini jvoulais boxer ou de
di maio je pense que c'est voilà il a la
légitimité de draps qui sont autorités y
compris morale enfin et bien évidemment
politique s'il tire la sonnette d'alarmé
ne manquera sans doute pas de le faire
il sera il sort en tant que fan en mai
au conseil européen c'est à mon avis
c'est ce qu'ils disent et c'est ce qui
va se passer mais ça reste à une
question importante
moi je suis tout à fait d'accord avec
vous il faut traiter cette question des
migrants s'y met on le sait on va les
traiter et ça va être l'appel d'air sur
cet espoir béatrice giblin oui balle et
ça fait du bien après un match un peu un
peu lourd merci en tout cas merci à tous
les deux d'avoir participé à ce match
des idées on se retrouve demain à 18
heures et à 20
heures 30 pour un nouveau numéro d'
allons plus loin demain matin bonjour
chez vous dès 7h30 au rayonnement de
chine heroes sera notamment jacqueline
gourault ministre de la cohésion des
territoires et des relations avec les
collectivités territoriales excellente
soirée sur public sénat
à
revoir ce programme en replay sur public
sénat